girl powers in full effect Nancy felt
really good you know there was a very
impressive list of honorees and
headlining that list miss Gwen Stefani
who stopped only to talk to us before
giving her man Blake Shelton and
emotional shout out for the ages
it was a year and a half ago I was I was
in a pool of Tears and I was so
disappointed and I'm really really
grateful to Blake Shelton for kissing me
back to life thank you so much I am I'm
going away can you describe your year
this year was incredible this year was
like someone said hey wake up and I was
like whoa oh my god I thought I was seen
in color but now I'm really seeing in
color a year and 10 days after they
officially started dating Gwen and Blake
are making us feel all the fields like
Sheldon yeah that fella
it's incredible to have a best friend
like that guy he's an amazing person but
check out what it took for this couple
to be together for Gwen's big glamour
women of the Year award
9:45 a.m. the to take a chopper ride
leaving Blake's Oklahoma ranch Eunice
alert then they board a private plane
together a burger appears to be the
in-flight meal we're getting started
Lana as Gwen gets glam Blake jets over
to take the VoiceLive around 7 o'clock
she steps into her straight off the
runway Marchesa gown and does the red
carpet solo just past 9:00 Blake is
there in time to see Gwen honored with a
pretty sweet throwback video one is a
little girl she was always kind and
sweet thoughtful I love to dress up with
my mom's clothes everything that you
went through you've come out stronger
than ever and better than ever what do
you attest that to I was thinking about
that on the drive over here and I was
thinking about just that little seed
that was planted in you and I
girl that little seed of fate and just
being able to watch that grow I guess
through tragedy now there I am